so this was Justin versus who vs. who
Matt Flynn okay Justin you're white okay
so Justin start off with e4 good start
so far c5 that's the Cillian defense
Knight f3 g6 and d4 so black goes for a
hyperaccelerated dragon
so the g6 is I played this a lot and one
of the idea is well for one thing
compared to the regular dragon you know
how you usually get the dragon right d6
d4 takes takes Knight f6 Knight c3 g6
for one thing in this one d6 pawn is
pushed up one Square and we're there's a
big difference if it's only moved if it
hasn't moved yet you might have a chance
to play d5 in one move and that changes
things a lot but yeah I mean so it
changes the way white can play for
instance here white can play Bishop here
Bishop here here castles Queen d2 knight
c6 and Castle queenside because d5 loses
a move
I mean d5 is the main move here but you
can't really afford to do that in the
accelerated drag the disadvantage it
also avoids for instance check this
should be 5 check g6 doesn't allow this
but the disadvantage is that maybe white
will be able to get and will because
black won't be a play Knight of 6 early
on and making white play Knight c3 it
means that why it's gonna be able to
play my Roxy bind with c4 if he wants to
so g6 ok d4 ok C takes now you can also
delay with Bishop g7 delay the the
capture of a tier White has this kind of
dangerous variation like takes the pawn
back
but takes the pawn back and then here
and now over the night threatening to
come up to two maybe two b5 and Bishop
III and these moves are gaining time
this is it's a dangerous line for black
I mean it's playable I've played this
but it's pretty dangerous white gets a
big lead in development so for instance
d6 night b5 threatening Bishop e3
which would take the a pawn and then if
a six then you're good
Bishop e3 hitting the Queen Queen us to
go to c6 and then Knight a seven I have
to guard that Bishop trade and then you
could continue with the attack with
Queen b3 and Bishop c4 coming ornate
five moves yeah on the other hand if
black could develop and get castled in
time he has a very strong position is
very strong positionally he has no
weaknesses in his position as long as he
manages to get castle but it looks like
a dangerous line because it's based on
what I've seen from here but okay so
what was the name of flex player hood
black matte okay so Matt Matt decided to
take right away and Justin took with the
night another possibility is to take
with a queen oops fakers a queen and
then for instance a5 that's a whole
other line
yeah oh I just accidentally I just
accidentally deleted the rest of the
game is there an undo here okay uh-huh
okay so night takes okay
so you went Bishop g7 and here's where
ye could use the possibility of playing
the maracas see vine and place c4 so
this way he puts the pawn in front of
the night and this helps them to control
the d5 square and it reduces any player
black has on the C file like in the
normal Sicilian on the other hand it
blocks this Bishop and it's delays
White's development and it weakens a
dark square so it's a trade off but most
people prefer to take this option yeah I
mean theoretically because otherwise
everyone would play this instead of the
regular dragon the whole point of the
regular dragon you play Knight f6 to
force Knight c3 and that move order what
we were seeing Knight f3 d6 Knight of 6
so he played he's able to play Knight of
6 and force Knight c3 basically I mean
Bishop d3 gives other options but and
this way white doesn't get the option of
playing there so that's why c4 is
logical but ok Bishop e3 is a move as
well knight c6 again y could play c4
Knight f6 is another possibility which
would cut that out
notice what would happen after he 5
Queen a 5 yeah so this is typical
tactics and then if Knight c3 White's
block the pawn and black can go into the
you know back to this okay that's
probably what we got in the game knight
c6 again like to play c4 he went Bishop
c4 matt matt played east 6 which is
really i don't like that move at all i
mean i think this creates huge holes are
you are you mad or Susan is mag here no
okay okay I mean this this move creates
huge holes I mean I'm like in the whites
position
I mean blacks position so I white just
castle which looks reasonable but
couldn't you I would really yeah my
first instinct is to go Knight b5 and b2
is hanging I know I don't really care
about b2 because the dark squares are
just awful right maybe I could 26:1
possible within he has Bishop e5 right
yeah I mean I would just want I would
really wanted yeah maybe maybe we maybe
do something like a 6 no yeah maybe you
were right not to maybe it doesn't lead
anywhere it just looks like the first
thing to look at it 92 I mean surely
White has a lot of compensation but
maybe you don't have to do this anyway
oh no you can't take the exchange black
should not take to exchange here that's
busted for black but I'm thinking maybe
something like a 6 something like a 6
and then I mean it's got to be good for
a white right and what can how can black
play this way this is terrible but maybe
that's what you should do because if you
if you Castle you give them a chance to
play nighty-night easly isn't after you
can play 97 because now night b5 doesn't
quite hit the mark yeah you play 97 and
now and I mean it might still be good
for a white but it's it's like I would
go straight for that I would do this you
know I mean I don't I don't care about I
would just want him to take that okay
more development and if you take the
rope just for those who don't
I mean who don't believe that's what
people experience just players know that
this is gonna be terrible for blacks
it's not going to end unhappiness no the
dark squares are just too weak and
blacks position maybe you know if six
and now we could play for instance
coming here and then 96 is coming on
that type of thing
the discovered check if like this black
moves too you know or just in general I
mean black camp can't survive this
position we could just castle but he his
pieces are started working you know it's
too much
too much for four but to deal with but
if he doesn't take the rook okay I'm
checking on d6 if he goes important
tactic of d5 I take right yeah and then
I what am I going to yeah Bishop takes
and this way this Queen takes then I
have Knight c7 otherwise you know
position is wide open
White's about to castle and nice c4
coming that type of thing I mean
immediately I can go Knight c4 and again
if black takes the exchange this is this
is really scary this is not just no good
dark squares are too weak so yeah I
think you should play that right away
because castles now 97 now 95 blacks
ready to Castle or maybe he can even get
away with d4 good
well d5 you can take - yeah I mean b2 is
now is also hanging subdued you can you
can really yeah I guess you can't really
do this because after all the trades b2
is hanging at the end so it takes Knight
c7 and takes and then Knight and there
should be two and here in the ending it
may not be enough compensation
no no sense and you know but even even
castles because it's a big difference if
blacks able to castle the knight on d6
it's gonna get on your mind somehow and
there should be two can grab this now
the knight has to go there and then
maybe some stuff but yeah so yeah an IP
5 wasn't looking to but yeah immediate
Knight b5 definitely are you gonna do
that I think
okay so castles now you were Knight d5
and I suppose again d5 makes sense he
but black my day six which yeah forcing
the knight to go where it probably just
wants to go anyway yeah I suppose whites
better in any case I mean e6 it's not a
good move musics is very terrible after
everything practically weights better I
just definitely go for that that
nice-looking attack with the immediate
Knight b5 and okay so you went a6 need
there b5 okay it's really gonna be hard
to shake off white script after letting
the knight into these six I suppose d5
but black gets the pawn back on B to
look after this for instance but White's
pieces are far more you know maybe you
don't have to go rip e1 but in case
White's pieces are far more active here
now which c5 and 96 and actually blacks
getting killed right so yeah I don't
like blacks position after okay so a 6
ok Knight piece and d6 b5 why did you go
to d3 though why not go to yeah you're
blocking the D file go to b3 and Bishop
Knight well you saw what he trades off
your bish opening that's the bound to
happen he could have gone Knight e5 if
he went Bishop d3 if he wanted to
does the bishop is not good on d3 you
should be happy he trades it off and
that's not that great of a bishop anyway
facing these pawns on e6 and f7 but here
okay I guess my next thing would be
maybe let's go before try to clamp down
with e5 or maybe attack with f5 also
perhaps finding this without allowing
black to cookie 5 trade off the bishop
but mainly mainly I just want to have 5
it's gonna be really well I mean after
have 5 I'm gonna be threatened after 6
right I know it's blacks move now it was
it
I'm gonna have to take the bishop I
think you should do something like this
because the attack looks too strong but
then again you know now we're cramped
now we're clamping down on the kingside
I mean look at this I mean look at this
Knight on d6 the Kings side is separated
from the Queen side this this black has
no space there and there are other I
kind of wouldn't want to close the
position down but I guess looks like the
best you got right now for looks like
like the thing to do right
I was probably so d4 give us black some
some spaceman I suppose trade I'm right
here
no hmm yeah your night is a little bit
loose and yeah yeah this also looks good
for white something like that yeah
Bishop d4 is also a good idea
yeah Bishop d3 no and you know if it
should be through you I mean probably
white it's still better if you're gonna
move your Bishop back you might as well
move it - II - but d3 it blocks the D
file but b34 sure to keep it out of the
way I mean that [ __ ] look is kind of
just getting in the way here Queen c7
okay so you disturbed your knight Bishop
c5 now before I don't like because this
muster some tactic and I'm missing it
looks like it just lets the night in I
think maybe black can do something like
this yeah okay with the bishops under
attack so what do you do you got a
serious chance of actually just losing
the knight on d4 d6 if you're okay but
before now there's problems on this long
diagonal no okay
so b4 okay Knight a 4 and now Queen a5
yeah I see it it's nice to trap the
Queen if it takes to do it okay
mmm but I feel like Queen a 5 doesn't
seem right because I mean what about it
maybe this new black should try it maybe
before was right actually maybe you just
need to avoid that this way White's
position White's pieces are still
somewhat b1 okay and try to find some
way to
let's move
and I have a check I can take on each
team I know yeah and then I'll go I
gotta go
t6
I do that
six
and with that Bishop on c8 it's pretty
tough you really you can look at it
carefully and try to find some sort of
tactic care of it and I don't think
before is right whatever ever seen Nate
I mean 94 and or 90 yeah one of these 94
95 but yeah probably white always holds
on to the everything it's looks a little
bit shaky there's some tactic which I'm
not seeing but okay so Bishop
so before Queen a5 okay a3 good move
yeah if Queen takes a four then a takes
before the Queen is trapped
that's nice tactic tactics and service
of strategy hmm I suppose that I suppose
that even it even c4 is fine for you but
a3 is better
so yeah a3 is very good so you took rook
takes Bishop takes B - okay that's
asking for it a little bit yeah you know
now there's Knight c4 I guess oh yeah so
do you play what can I stay for yeah I
mean without but I blacks see the bishop
on c8 I mean really really blacks
big mistake here with what do you think
there's one move that's completely to
blame ye six it's completely to blame
for everything black suffering here it's
antic positional move you can't really
it's not a Sicilian con you can't really
get away with that when you and then
later letting the night come to d6 it's
just not something you can consider
maybe playing a six at some point to
stop 95 or even then White was gonna
have play on the dark squares but okay
so this would be 2 + HC 4 okay
went between there Bishop there just
gave up the Queen this is all over now I
mean basically white could also take on
B - right
it's more accurate I would say - just
take on b2 you're just up a piece rather
than having to play with two pieces
against a queen but here at least
oh yeah okay yeah okay
so then then it was all so black only
has one bishop for the Queen that's
probably not gonna be enough what was
what was bad about how you played
self-criticism is good I mean you're up
a queen so I mean you have King f2 and
whatever okay Bishop it's dull it's
nothing you know Ken can't you check
meet him by the way don't you ever meet
here so we're so wait this is what so
you missed meeting one basically yeah
okay so Bishop a6 wasn't a very good
move because it allowed me into
okay so Queen f6 King g8 would give you
another chance to get it okay
why didn't you just
I mean King f2 okay whatever it is
matter night to heal how to discover you
okay you did actually make some mistakes
but it wasn't still not enough to mess
up this game I thought that now you have
Maidan - I don't see anything else
really the King walks away and every
line I can I don't see any trying to
tricks there and yeah oh you know good
game I mean II 6 was the big mistake on
blacks part of course going back but
that's the funny thing because instead
of e6000 any five that's that's trouble
for a white best move is probably see
three of it that takes the square from
the from the from the night on the night
of six hitting the upon and after this
you know maybe castles there's lines
like that you know and now blacks also
got a chief or coming because there's d5
in some cases I don't know about here
here I guess you know you got ninety
five inning that and then even a g4 or
something the big thing is really night
belong it's been c3 so yeah c3 a alright
I've definitely had this position my
opponent was like a 2001 when Knight c3
Queen before and it okay does anyone
have any other games if nobody has any
any games I can show you a game that
student was showing me actually I'll
tell you what I'll show you the game I
played in the ladder I think I can
remember it was from early it was from
like three weeks ago when I first got
here I mean they wanted me to play a
ladder game and I played against about a
1900 this is the game I was saying about
unbalanced position or an off balance
position where why and I'll just show
you how I was back black so I'm gonna
flip it around I don't know how you do
that
okay okay he start off like this this I
think was like 1900 or something and
that I went here he went here or
actually he went to see for I believe it
just is going to be the same thing and I
played to Kings Indian Kings Indian but
I also play e6 he went Knight c3 Bishop
g7 and here one night of three so I
castled I'm keeping the most flexible I
don't need to play d6 yet because he
hasn't played e4 so it might as well
make the most the move that I'm gonna
need in in every case castling for
instance I'm gonna now I keep the option
to play c5 or d5 and he played Bishop
before so this is some sort of let's say
relative like a of a London system but
c4 has been played instead of using the
London you play c3 which is much more
solid and so here I struck back with c5
okay so basically I went so yeah by by
not playing d6 I I've got the option
still to play d5 or play see five it
doesn't make a huge different I mean d6
was reasonable but here for instance now
I get to play c5 and I think white
system is very commonly used nuts so
used so much with Bishop f4 or Bishop g5
is far more common here this is a Smith
Slav system much more common way of
playing it's a little it's a little
different because the bishop is not as
exposed here some cases so I had this
simple or something like this in the
tournament recently but okay he went
Bishop f4 and I went to c5 I'm just
trying to get things get the business
going quickly you know I could play
other ways but I want first of all the
Queen the bishop is away from the Queen
side and so a lot of times when people
develop this Queen Bishop early on you
can hit with c5 and then expose some
weaknesses on the Queen side so now he
played III and this is the first real
mistake I would say basically a mistake
I mean looks like a normal move right
but we'll be seeing it this is kind of
it's a mistake and I don't know exactly
how to explain it with the bishop
doesn't belong on f4 in this structure
it's gonna be exposed on f4 so how do
you think I'm glad have played d5 and
the way I was thinking I would meet d5
was something like d3 with idea of
playing a five or maybe six depending
like let's say he goes age three to keep
the Bishop for the retreat
Ranko a5 because in the structure if the
bishop goes away I gained time and I got
this just this kind of structure and if
he takes and and accepts this pawn
sacrifice that gets pretty good play
here even can take a second pawn right
within you know it's two pawns okay well
maybe some of you wouldn't do this but
if you if you look at this position now
what do you think's going you want to
play this position is why you get a lot
of problems to deal with it's two pawns
but I'm you mission
hanging bishops yeah bishops hanging 94
it's coming Bishop c4
you know 97 stuff knight c6 Knight F to
d7 you know if white goes before Queen
here hitting this night when yeah white
resign and this is terrible
well I don't know I mean there's night
b5 then yeah but before camp can't be I
couldn't move her like maybe five I
suppose no no I can't go there but yeah
because you can take some go to c4 yeah
what else gonna why you do here hmm
yeah see pawn is hanging it is for you
doesn't look like it works yeah no this
looks like whites positions collapsing
here I think he's got to play Queen c1
but yeah it looks like Danger Danger
position I cuz they're white does have
nice c7 coming at the end
I mean 94 it takes takes or b1
maybe before is because of Queen c7 in
at some Queen b6 or 95 type moves oh you
probably just really just go here cuz I
don't care about 95 there's too much
stuff coming down on wait for and to be
able to go and grab the Brooke on a 8
you can night in 84 and now no bishops
III is coming if the knight moves clean
a sixes in 87 yeah that's like um okay
my Queens hanging and I just moved my
queen somewhere and then take the knight
and win the Queen looks like good enough
any in case it's no point but to see how
okay I mean white doesn't obviously have
to take the pawn he shouldn't take the
second pawn if he takes if he is gonna
well if he takes to the queen and
another theory of this two wheel which
is you know clean a finds looks like
trouble for white to a knight c6 Oracle
da 94 all coming I mean I was thinking
about playing or ye6 there's another
possibility not allowing him to just
move the bishop away
he takes it's the same right and if not
I'm taking there with a Benoni with a
bishop on f4 like this and this is some
line so okay I mean white can play that
way also okay so but he he played e3 a
normal-looking move especially if you
want to be safe right he doesn't want to
go into the Benoni type structure pushes
D pawn open up my bishop and starts
looking all scary right so he played a
solid safe move but just not a solid
safe move so I took on d4 well actually
I was gonna ask you how you're gonna
play but I just okay all I just showed
you but okay so he took back with a pawn
if he takes to the knight then this
Bishop doesn't belong here either maybe
taking the knight is safer but again I
got moves like okay d6 would threaten
the fork so it already gained some time
I might consider instead knight c6 just
keeping all the flexibility again and
planning d5 or something like that or to
take on d4 and if he takes I'm happy
here I think I would you know how would
you take back by the way in this
position
so I think both moving yeah well I think
they're both quite reasonable cause of
the b-pawn I'm gonna get play on the I'm
gonna get a lot I'm gonna play d6 and
rook b8 in Queen a5 and we get a lot of
play on the on the Queen side I think
before he can consolidate but it's not
like it's so easy to build up a center
here I mean the best I could get would
be a reverse Greenfeld if that were the
case it weren't for the fact that this
bishops out here it wouldn't be a you
know taking when the D pawn is also good
for black I'd say because in this
position with a C pawn up here the
bishop is gonna be strong on the long
diagonal the pawn is exposed and you
know it's possible for black to push his
e pawn later on so it's kind of ona way
he took with his his e pawn and now how
would you play here had a lot of games I
think I had some game with someone today
yes yeah d5 you know in hoops d5 and now
I'm basically gonna trade these pawns
and create isolated Queen pawn this
Bishop on f4 doesn't belong there it
should either be on g5 putting pressure
on e7 or on e3 protecting the pawn but
on f4 it's just exposed to a vengeful
Knight to d5
our night to hit Knight to d5 later on
like if takes already for instance I'm
attacking the bishop and if he trades
here well I mean this is the perfect
isolated Queens pawn position we've
traded a few pieces the bishop has aimed
here nights coming there my king is
totally safe Bishop g4 is coming it's a
dream position you know and c5 probably
what he should probably what he should
do is something like just get castled as
fast as you can by Sentai Bishop e2 and
then I and then I'm gonna trade and gain
a tempo and then I'm gonna keep
developing and this Bishop should be
better off somewhere else but c5 is
something some people might want to make
but now moves like 94 and I'm getting
ready to go b6 and break up the pawn so
it takes and b6 and that type of thing
if he takes of course then and this you
know he's still not castled and the
on his trouble so he went Queen b3 this
is here when I'm gonna talk about a off
balance or type of position I take I
took bishop takes okay White has a huge
lead and development right huh yeah I
mean White has a huge lead in
development it looks like within which
you realize rural development not just
like pure getting your pieces off the
back of the board in fact whites behind
them development here he's not gonna get
castled in fact if I can if I can I mean
he can castle using it's going to cost
him upon more than upon and see a bishop
on f4 is badly placed unguarded and not
relevant and vulnerable bishop on c4 and
Queen on B three are badly placed Queen
in Tibet is out of out of coordination
on b3 now I got maybe ideas like Knight
a5 but I also I'm threatening this pawn
and my biggest ideas Bishop g4 to attack
the knight on f3 I would love to take
that night double the pawns and then
take the pawn on d4 yeah so if he
castles I suppose I didn't want to take
the pawn on d4 because well it's great
for black I got an extra center pawn but
you know the game goes on and I'm not I
have to put it in some work too you know
yeah I would have played Bishop g4 I
think now I'm still you know giving him
problems with the pond
I'm just getting ground but I'd like to
take the knight and then take the pond
draw his King into the firing line it
goes here I'll take if he takes the
knight i take with a bishop and that's
that you know okay i'm up upon that time
but we've traded a pair of pieces and my
bishops very well placed or maybe after
d5 i would do something like this just
yeah this is better i probably and take
the bishop and take tonight and then
rook c8 and king has busted up and
probably a ways to win that pawn anyway
on d5 okay going back he
um he went queen a4 so what do you do
now this is just a pure trap but what do
you do now I take the deep on my happens
if I take the D pawn
yeah he takes through the night and then
Queen takes right yeah okay brilliant
idea okay I'm not gonna fall for that
what did I do
I went okay I got several good moves I
think I went Bishop d7 yeah Bishop d7
just threatened just making his Queen
move away you know if he goes Bishop b5
I go a6 and now he's losing material or
he's getting you know terrible position
takes takes take here if the Queen takes
I take on d4 maybe extra pawn for
nothing I suppose like dad I probably
would have I think I went behind then
he's so he stepped off of the basically
if he went Queen d1 which i think is
probably best I was gonna go Bishop g4
and I get I'm getting ready to take
tonight and then the D pawn and it's
just it's no good for white yeah I still
no no no I'll take and just take her the
G pawn if that happens I'm happy I don't
need my pop I would rather not be up a
pawn I'd rather just do they think make
him do that I think okay I did go Bishop
d7 oh yeah okay cuz I mean looks like
there's a lot of other good moves but it
I probably was just kind of whatever
okay so he went he went Quint Queen to
c2 because he didn't want to yeah this
is what happened he didn't want to go
all the way back to d1 a lot of times
people don't want to admit you know they
don't want to just go home with the
piece but you got to look at each
position that's different as new you
know going back to d1 was the way to go
the best chance at least so now I went
Bishop g4 which I asked you guys to
guess Simoes
mr. g4 okay so of course I want to take
his night and he Castle queenside now
what do you think I did here yeah a lot
of good moves what do you think
bishop where well I would have done that
last move if I was going to that was
also a good move here it was also a good
move here but no I mean Bishop f5 it's
it's you know he goes here okay I mean I
love my position that's true
there's no doubt about that but it's he
has its chances to somehow get you know
d5 and then 94 there's simpler ways here
I mean it's also gonna get his King into
this firing line cripsy it is good
that's a good move nothing wrong with
that but okay I just took on f3 because
I see that here I mean it's real simple
that I'm his King is gonna fall into the
firing line my Knights gonna be totally
solid there so he went Queen a for his
idea well what do you think his idea is
now it takes d4 he likes that idea well
what do I did now I'm like he probably
was you know he's got pin on the D file
looks all dangerous and everything I got
my pawn but and Bishop e5 maybe it's a
throne but did my next move probably
like he was a little bit this is five
yeah nine th five is good but there's
even better than that it's the right
idea visit 1995 Bishop III e5 would be
fine but that's you know big advantage
winning for black let's say but there's
better than that simpler
hmm b5 all night takes right there's
something here you know it doesn't work
so I need to be so speculative here we
already got a pawn in the bag and
weights King is in the firing line black
king is totally safe
right I want to uncover this bishop
right do I need my night on h5m hmm well
that's what he said I mean ih5 is pretty
decent because it's you know then next
to z5 but why do I want my night over
there his position still off-balance
look at these pieces f4 see for a4
there's problems there so I went 97 so
I'm guarding that all right I'm getting
ready to play e5 if I need to but I'm
also planning Knight b6 now you see five
well that's the exchange it was exchange
if he does that then this is really easy
and this exchange down and just nothing
I move my my knight to b6 and force a
queen trade for instance she has to
guard well doesn't force the Queen trade
but I mean you know you see what I'm
what I'm saying his Queen Esther guard
the bishop if it was here I go like
Knight c4 or something doesn't look good
no I wasn't worried about that he wants
to give up all his material and play on
that's fine he went rook d3 but really
there's nothing much we can do here
Knight here for instance I probably go
u5 and then rook ca next because that's
also coming Rick c8 is another thing you
might rook d3 what would you do here a
couple good moves right but what's the h
c5 is the first name P a lot of people
just bang that down is it Oh 95 maybe he
would resigned after that I don't know
but it's not the best move and I and I
spend another like 5 seconds to find the
actual best move e5 whatever that's fine
but this I can win a whole piece
it's still the same thing I mean he goes
Bishop III and then Knight c5 back to d1
and you can't resign or you can play on
but it's I'd rather win a whole piece on
the exchange he's more likely to resign
after being down a whole piece Knight b6
so I just okay I attack these two pieces
the only way you can guard is Bishop and
the queen is clean before now
we needs to guard the bishop huh
yeah a five now if Queen see five what
do I do
rook c8 yeah so instead of Queen I mean
then I win the bishop for free right and
and if and and if he took on d4 it was
35 I guess I think or maybe was the move
before for God
I think he might have anyway whatever he
something like this and then basically
took in any resign I think probably saw
that this is meth under the Queen's
guarded you know so that was that was
the game but was just looks like some of
his moves look pretty normal right I
mean first mistake is III which I'm sure
I mean a lot of people under 2000 would
make this move or under 2280 but already
black has a great game the bishop
doesn't belong on f4 in this position